over nearly half a century hip-hop has
become hugely popular worldwide but it
also is being viewed with suspicion by
law enforcement with lyrics sometimes
used in criminal trials against artists
here are some of the major companies in
the music industry that have signed a
petition against that practice there's
also legislation calling for it to be
restricted one current example of that
that's getting a lot of attention the
upcoming trial of rapper Young Thug
whose real name is Jeffrey Williams
prosecutors referenced several songs in
his indictment the grammy-winning artist
is charged with crimes related to gang
activity and racketeering that are
allegedly linked to murders and theft he
has pleaded not guilty CBS News
correspondent Skyler Henry went to New
Orleans to meet with the former rising
star who saw his career come to a halt
When lyrics were used against him in
court
this is something I wrote years ago in
prison that kind of uh this was my
therapy if you meet McKinley Phipps now
welcome to a place called easy the
food's real greasy the blocks are hot
women know up to ease it it's a far cry
from the 20 year old chart climbing
rapper known as Mack signed to music
mogul Masterpiece No Limit Records
his album Shell Shocked reached number
11 on the Billboard top 200 in 1998.
felt good to be a part of something that
was big it felt good to be a part of
something that was recognized all around
the world
but in an instant phipps's rise Came
Crashing Down in February of 2000 when a
19 year old man was shot during an
altercation at phipps's show at a
nightclub in Slidell Louisiana he later
died
detectives eventually took Phipps into
custody after Witnesses said he had a
gun I pulled my gun out when I ran
toward the door and that was probably
the biggest mistake I ever made I would
later learn that because people saw me
with this gun that's kind of why people
were like under the belief that maybe he
did it Phipps was charged with first
degree murder it was all on MTV News it
was on I never was on MTV until I go to
charge a member of phipps's Entourage
admitted to the shooting but he says
that confession fell on deaf ears during
the trial prosecutors zeroed in on the
same lyrics that made Phipps a star the
thing that you grew up loving to do from
the time he was seven years old gets
brought forth front and center and used
against you where is your mind do you
say that's not even what I said you took
two different songs splice them together
to make what you feel to basically make
the statement you wanted to make
one song was murder murder kill kill
which was like a straight battle rap
the other one was a song called shell
shock and the line that they referred to
was actually a line about my father they
said this young man said murder murder
kill kill if you f with me I'll put a
bullet in your brain not only do
prosecutors cherry pick lyrics and
decontextualize them to serve their own
purposes but they often do it without
any knowledge or understanding of rap
music at all Eric Nielsen co-author of
rap on trial and a professor at the
University of Richmond says rap lyrics
have been used as evidence in more than
500 cases against artists since 1991. in
your studies have there been cases in
other genres where their lyrics have
been considered in criminal prosecution
rap music is the only fictional Forum
musical or otherwise that is targeted
like this in the courts Nielsen says
phipps's case is one of the most
egregious he's ever seen I'm not here to
tell you that somebody is guilty or
innocent I'm only here arguing for a
person's right to a fair trial but I've
always had one exception and that
exception is Mac Phipps
a jury convicted fips of manslaughter
and sentenced him to 30 years in prison
former Georgia prosecutor Chris Timmons
what do you think of the strategy of
incorporating lyrics into prosecution as
a whole just as a strategy from a legal
perspective I mean if you've got a
confession whether that confession
Rhymes whether it's set to music you're
going to want to use it if you're a
prosecutor same thing with defense
you're going to want to keep it out I
mean Timmins who had no connection to
phipps's trial
has tried more than 100 cases and has
used rappers music videos to link them
to criminal street gangs I didn't use
any of their lyrics I didn't feel like
any of their lyrics were relevant to
this robbery but what I did use was the
lyrics and the video to show that these
people have a relationship Phipps served
21 years of the 30-year sentence and was
released from prison in 2021 after being
granted clemency I can definitely say
I'm more conscious of the messages that
I want to
convey to the audience I would never
censor myself but I do
value my words more
son of the city I'm one with the gritty
I come from the Slumber them not want to
pit today Mac is back his album son of
the city debuted last October his first
project since coming home from prison I
don't have too many songs if I have any
about prison life
because the whole time I was in prison I
I was imagining myself free never got
high high on the ground I was born with
a light blame God When the Shine I'm
Divine from the belly of the Beast home
feel like I ain't feeling better in some
weeks now Phipps needs permission from a
parole officer to leave Louisiana or
even stay out past 9 pm to perform and
travel across the country championing
reform to the legal strategy lawmakers
on the state and federal levels have
introduced legislation to help protect
art in Trials as well and guys this is
one of those things where people have
put a lot of pressure on a lot of
different legislations to try to step in
to help here that we've seen California
do this New York is considering
legislation as well and I talked about
this they're trying to bring this up on
the federal level as well yeah because
rappers believe it's a slippery slope
right like once you start pulling their
lyrics then where does the the Fine Line
lay when it comes to Artistic impression
right and and that was one of those
things where we asked a lot of the
rappers and you know up and comers as
well you have to tell the truth there's
that pressure to be genuine in your
inauthentic exactly exactly and while
some have been in the past and said that
may not have been my exact story they're
influenced by what they've seen and what
they've experienced but to hear 500
cases since 1991 where lyrics have been
used against and mainly rap artists yeah
right specifically targeting the rap
industry I also thought it was
interesting when he said listen you know
someone else was arrested for the
confessed to the crime right and he's
still convicted and Mack is still
convicted and now that's one of those
things that he's working with you know
the District Attorney's office to try to
because he wants to be fully exonerated
of course he did not commit and so that
is one of those things where he's like I
have to keep fighting I have to make
sure that I'm able to be fully free so I
can get up and do what I love to do he
did have a certain style it sounds like
that's right based on what you showed
rapping from when he was seven years old
yeah come on it's a talent Skyler Henry
thank you always good to see you in New
York yeah at the table I like it